produced with exclusive support from
bearing a Ingelheim the biggest killer
in the Western world is thrombosis
thrombosis happens when a clot forms
inside an artery or a vein obstructing
the flow of blood when the clot blocks
one of the main arteries in the heart it
causes a heart attack if the clot forms
in a deep vein in the leg which can
happen when a patient is stuck in bed
it's called deep vein thrombosis
typically the leg swells up and the
danger is that the clot will dislodge
and travel to the lungs causing a
pulmonary embolism
sometimes a clot gets lodged in the
brain starving the tissue of oxygen and
causing a stroke for half a century
doctors have been using a drug called
warfarin to try to prevent thrombosis
warfarin is an anticoagulant it's
popularly known as a blood thinner but
in fact it doesn't affect the thickness
or viscosity of blood instead it
decreases the quantity of proteins that
normally allow blood to clot but
warfarin is a problematic drug and for
50 years scientists have been on a quest
to replace it the story actually begins
more than 50 years ago in the cattle
ranches of North America in the 1920s
farmers noticed their cows were bleeding
to death after minor medical procedures
and sometimes spontaneously this was
Depression era and to save money farmers
were feeding their cattle spoiled hay
made from sweet clover it turned out
that something in the sweet clover was
stopping the cows blood from clotting
properly in 1941 scientists identified
the culprit an anticoagulant called die
Coomer ol warfarin is a more potent form
of die Coomer ole and initially it was
used to poison rats but when a US army
recruit tried and failed to commit
suicide with warfarin doctors realized
they could turn this poison into a
life-saving drug
one early recipient was US President
Eisenhower who was given the drug after
suffering a heart attack in the Western
world today warfarin is a commonly
prescribed drug and you probably know
somebody who takes it as we age and
especially if our diet is full of
cholesterol fatty deposits buildup in
our veins and arteries these deposits
known as atherosclerosis plaques narrow
the vessels and make blood flow sluggish
sometimes a plaque ruptures exposing
material that activates platelets in the
blood and triggers a clot the platelets
clump together and are held in place by
a protein called fibrin fibrin is the
end product of the coagulation cascade
warfarin reduces fibrin production by
disrupting reactions further up the
Cascade it does this by inhibiting an
enzyme called vitamin K at POC side
reductase but warfarin has many
drawbacks it's slow to take action it
interacts with other drugs and people
vary in their response meaning patients
must be monitored regularly to get the
dose right because of these
complications say doctors some people at
risk from thrombosis are not treated in
the late-1980s
a growing awareness that thrombosis was
a major cause of heart attacks and
strokes fueled the search for a better
anticoagulant drug blood clotting is a
natural and often useful process it
stops us bleeding too much when we
injure ourselves so any new drug needs
to prevent dangerous clotting but
without causing excess bleeding bleeding
is one of the main side effects of
warfarin so what exactly were scientists
looking for the coagulation cascade is a
series of protein activation reactions
involving enzymes called proteases
designing inhibitors that target
proteases is tricky another key
challenge is to design a drug that can
be taken orally as warfarin can so that
patients can treat themselves at home
eventually scientists identified two
promising drug targets factor 10a and
thrombin
factor 10a plays a central role in the
coagulation cascade by catalyzing the
production of thrombin and
thrombomodulin
to fibrin the stuff which acts like the
glue in the clot studies showed that
both factor 10a and thrombin could be
suppressed without causing bleeding
complications
what's more solving the crystal
structure of thrombin helped scientists
find drugs to target this key enzyme in
the last decade clinical trials have put
factor 10a inhibitors and thrombin
inhibitors to the test after 50 years of
searching there are three new oral
anticoagulants on the market which could
eventually replace warfarin there's
dabigatran which inhibits thrombin and
then rivaroxaban and apixaban which
inhibit factor 10a other drugs are still
in clinical trials for doctors and
patients this is a real milestone having
a better treatment for thrombosis will
benefit many of us produced with
exclusive support from baring Ingelheim